اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى بدير البلح اهلا بكم مجازر
اسرائيليه جديده في غزه في مناطق ماهوله
بالسكان بجباليا والنصيرات والشجاع وزاره
الصحه في القطاع تعلن ارتفاع عدد الشهداء
الى اكثر من
10600 ومدير المستشفى الاندونيسي يقول ان
محيطها يتعرض لقصف اسرائيلي متواصل وان
الكهرباء ستنقطع خلال ساعات بسبب نف هذه
الوقود الاعلام الحكومي في غزه يقول ان
اسرائيل تمارس حرب تجويع على سكان القطاع
مقرر الامم المتحده للحق في الغذاء يقول
للجزيره ان السكان في غزه يتعرضون لخطر
الاباده الجماعيه وبرنامج الاغذيه العالمي
يحذر من تداعيات كارثيه لنقص الماء والوقت
كتائب القسام تعلن قنص جندي وتدمير عدد من
الدبابات والاليات الاسرائيليه في مناطق
عده من غزه الجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن مقتل
جندي اضافي وارتفاع عدد قتلاه منذ بدء
العمليه البريه الى
33 وهيئه البث الاسرائيليه تكشف ان تل
ابيب طلبت من واشنطن شراء 200 مسيره
انتحاريه مجلس النواب الامريكي يتبنى
مشروع قرار يوبخ النائب الامريكيه من اصول
فلسطينيه رشيد طليب ويتهمها بالترويج
لروايه كاذبه بشان هجوم حماس على اسرائيل
وتدعو الى تدمير دوله اسرائيل في حين ردت
طليب بالقول ان انتقادها كان موجها
للحكومه الاسرائيليه وتصرفات نتنياهو
مضيفه ان اعتبار ذلك الانتقاد معاداه
للساميه يشكل سابقه خطيره للغايه الى
اللقاء